- Hey everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
So everybody who listens to the podcast,
I've been wanting to do this
concept for a long time.
I did a version of it not too long ago.
A couple episodes of the Brown Paper Bags
where we drink wine, but
these three wonderful people
are not gonna get served free alcohol.
- Bye.
- Yeah, I know, sorry, you're out?
You were promised something
totally different, right?
- It's so nice.
Thank you so much.
- You're out.
I've always been
fascinated by what happens
when you bring different people together
that are doing interesting things
and just shoot the shit about what's going
on in culture, in the game.
And I think a lot of people are,
in this group specifically,
I think from what I know
about them from afar, have crossovers
and see certain things the same way
and then obviously have
their unique journeys
and points of view.
So I've been wanting to do--
There's this thing that I used to do
when I was first coming up
in the game in Silicon Valley
where I met all the hardcore Facebook
and Twitter founders and Uber founders.
And they were called jam sessions
where we would get together
at these conferences
at like midnight in a hotel room
and for three, four hours just
talk about the game, right?
If we would have one tonight,
we would talk about
cryptocurrency, for sure.
We did four years ago.
That's why I bought
Bitcoin four years ago.
So you just get different
ideas and thoughts about--
We would argue about who's
gonna be big, who's not.
And so, I've been wanting to do this thing
called #podSessions, podcast
versions of the jam sessions,
and I'm very excited.
I have three phenomenal guests
and probably one of the biggest things
that I wanna get out of
#podSessions is also an opportunity
for me as my career
changes to use my platform
of the attention that I'm
amassing to put other people
on that also sometimes have
bigger audiences than me,
different audiences
than me, or are emerging
and are doing interesting
things that have caught my eye,
normally through some digital connection
or the eye of somebody on my
team's digital connection.
So that's what we're doing.
I'm super excited about it.
You guys are the three that
are helping me pop the cherry
of #podSessions.
- Love it.
Thank you.
- So thank you for being here.
And so, why don't we introduce ourselves.
Let's start with the ladies.
Saweetie, go ahead.
- Hey, I'm Saweetie.
I'm from LA, originally from the Bay Area.
And I'm an artist and recently
just released my single,
ICY GRL, and it's doing really well.
- What's really fun for me on this is that
you literally DMed me, and you were like,
"Yo, you're always in the room
with all these dude rappers."
- For real.
- "Why don't you bring a girl rapper."
- You gotta show some love.
- Good for you.
- Right, good, good.
- I've been trying to tell
people like it all happens--
- I had to shoot my shot.
- In the DM.
(girls laugh)
She's just like, "Yo, fuck you, GaryVee.
"Let's get the ladies in here."
I'm like, "She's right."
- [Cipha Sounds] Yeah, she's right.
- And here I am.
- And now she's sitting
right here, love it.
Let's keep it going.
- Claudia Oshry, Girl With No Job.
Husband, I mean not a husband,
wife of Boy With No
Job, who works for you.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Real name's Claudia Oshry from New York,
live in New York, went
to school in New York,
love New York, never wanna leave.
Everyone keeps telling
me I should move to LA,
but I would rather die.
That's it.
- Are you and Saweetie
about to fight?
- No we had the conversation peacefully
before we got here.
- Got it, good.
I'm with you, by the way.
LA can seduce me when I'm
there like on the second day
'cause the sun is like,
fuck, right?
- And the trees.
- But, it's too slow for me.
Even New York's starting
to get weirdly slow.
- That's true.
- I might have to move
to China.
- It's just the traffic.
(Saweetie and Claudia laugh)
- So a lot of people listening here
between your amazing
husband, who I know very well
'cause he works at Vayner
on the influencer world.
The Girl With No Job
and the Boy With No Job.
So first of all, which
account started first?
- Oh, mine.
- Yeah.
- Very important.
- She's like, "Ooh."
- Everyone should know.
- Yes, so Girl With No Job is a monster.
Now everybody does know.
So Girl With No Job is a
monster Instagram account.
We'll get into the origins of that,
but going well, you're
super happy, all going well?
- Oh, very pleased.
- Good.
Then you love New York.
- Life's wonderful.
Knock on wood, and I love New York.
- My man.
- Cipha Sounds.
I also love New York,
and I don't wanna leave.
DJ, comedian, and everything in between.
- [Gary] Yes.
- I don't have as many
followers as Girl With No Job
that I just noticed.
- Most humans don't.
- No, they had just shrunk
my ego just severely
when I followed her.
I'm gonna get there.
- I get it.
You gotta achieve to something, right?
Gotta have a North Star.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Alright, let's go back around
and create the two minute origin story.
Like tell me about your early days,
what got you going, how
you became an artist.
I played your single on repeat
all the way down on my winter vacation.
- For real?
- Uh huh.
I especially like when
anytime people are talking
about pasta and seafood
dishes, I get excited.
That was my favorite.
If I was back to the old
days that I used to listen
to music with a tape and rewound,
I would've just kept hitting rewind there.
It's a lot easier now to
just slide the finger back.
So born and raised in LA?
- No, born and raised in the Bay Area.
- [Gary] Got it.
- Yeah, so what took me to LA is
so I was writing since
I was like 14 years old.
- Writing?
- Writing like raps.
So I've been wanting to do this.
However, I didn't have the resources.
- Of course.
- I didn't have the plan.
So I went to college.
San Diego but I was like,
"Okay this is a B market city.
"I need to go to a A market."
- Big shout out to San Diego.
That's a B market.
I think that's a compliment.
I think San Diego is a C market.
Keep going.
(group laughs)
- Okay well, when I was talking
to people in the industry,
they were like, "You need to go to LA."
- [Gary] Of course.
- I wanted to go to the best college,
applied to USC, got in, graduated.
Still didn't have the resources,
so I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna do car raps.
That's what I was known for.
And I was like, someone's
gonna see these car raps.
Was doing it, couple of them went viral,
ended up meeting my manager,
and every since then, we've been rockin'.
He was like, "You need
to record Icy Girl."
- And how long ago was that?
- About nine months ago.
- Yeah, so for all of you not in the know,
car raps is like a genre
that's super interesting.
It just makes so much sense.
Now that we have cameras and
the ability to record anywhere.
I actually think my vlog is a car rap.
Like the amount of content DailyVee is
that's in the back of
my car is the majority
'cause we're so busy.
- Exactly.
- I've loved following that whole scene,
and there's been multiple
people that've popped off
from car rapping.
- Exactly.
- Did you see somebody popping and decide,
I'll do that too?
Or was it just kind of--
- No, so I had recorded
a couple in my car,
and I was like consistency
and familiarity is super
important with your viewers
and your audience.
So I was like, I'm just
gonna stay in the car.
- And are you cozy in that zone?
Does it feel like a booth?
- Yeah, it's my booth.
- [Gary] I think so, right?
- His name is Bruce.
- [Gary] You named your car?
- Bruce.
- Bruce the booth.
- Respect.
Girl With No Job, how
the hell did that happen?
- It happened because--
- Because you had no job?
- Well, actually it happened
because I had a job.
I went to NYU.
I was so bored.
Everyone at NYU was very career-oriented.
- By the way, this whole
New York narrative,
the NYU part made it so much better.
You would never leave, right?
- [Claudia] No like literally never.
- You will die in this city?
- 100%.
- [Gary] Do you even travel outside of it?
- Well, I was just in
Mexico, and it was beautiful
and everything, but I
couldn't wait to get home.
- [Gary] I get it.
Respect.
- I'm not a big traveler.
I don't wanderlust
or any of that.
- So out of 365 days a year,
you spend 352 in New York City?
- 363, honestly.
- [Gary] You went to Mexico for two days?
- No, I went to Mexico for four days.
- But literally, literally no joke,
you're spending three hund--
- Like 9/10ths.
- You're spending 350 days in the city.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And do you consider
Queens and Brooklyn the city?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Doesn't everyone?
The five boroughs.
- I don't.
(group laughs)
No, I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
But you consider all of those.
- [Claudia] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You don't consider Jersey the city?
- I mean that would be wrong.
- Be careful now.
Be careful now, I'm a Jersey boy.
No, I'm not saying anything
bad, but that would be wrong.
- But respect I get.
- What about Staten Island,
though?
- That would be correct.
- Yeah, what about Staten Island?
- It is a borough.
- It's a borough.
- But not the city.
- I'm not saying I spend
huge amounts of time there,
but I would definitely
consider it.
- Do you secretly hate Queens?
- Doesn't everyone?
(group laughs)
- So anyways, so what happens?
- So yeah, I started this blog.
I got an internship in fashion PR,
and this was like
pre-Condé Nast getting sued
and now having to pay interns here.
You should, it's the right thing to do.
- I don't think people should pay anybody,
but that's a whole different story
if you're giving them actual opportunity.
I'll explain that later.
I know it's an unpopular statement.
- Yes very.
- Tyler, I'm not paying you anymore.
(group laughs)
- So I got this internship.
It was six years ago.
It was unpaid.
It was like ungodly hours.
It was just horrible.
Everyone was super bitchy and mean
and skinny and like, fashion.
I'm the opposite of that.
I'm so cool, everyone loves me.
I was being so put down there.
So I started this blog
called Girl With A Job.
It was like on Tumblr.
It was the only way I knew how
to make a website back then
was on Tumblr.
- Girl With A Job.
- With A Job.
It was more like a diary.
I used it as a platform to talk shit
about literally everyone.
- Tumblr was a beast.
- Beast!
- You need to look right up there.
That is me investing in Tumblr.
- Great investment.
- Huge.
That, Twitter and Tumblr,
were a year before Facebook.
That's what put me on.
Tumblr is forever in my heart.
- No, if you have Tumblr followers,
you got followers everywhere.
- Everywhere.
- [Gary] I agree.
- And they're so loyal.
- They're so loyal.
As like an 18 year old who
knew nothing about computers.
I could make a website
without having to have a host
or like things that I know now.
It was just great.
- As young people, like
most of you are all young,
but doesn't it feel weird
that there's like 17
and 18 years olds that
don't know what Tumblr is?
- Yeah, it's really sad.
- Like the lack of Tumblr's existence,
does that fuck with you?
- Well no.
- Okay.
Are you excited about Vine 2?
- Um, yes.
- Me too.
Okay keep going.
- Very excited.
Okay, so I started this blog.
It was really like a diary.
Absolutely nobody read it, even like Ben.
Like no one read it.
- [Gary] You were dating Ben at the time?
- No actually we weren't dating yet,
so I forgive him for not reading it.
- Right, so what the
fuck are you mad at Ben?
Ben's just some kid
living his life.
- No, it's just
like an anology for people
close to me were not reading it.
- [Gary] I get it.
- And I eventually got
fired 'cause I was terrible.
They hated me, I hated them.
And I was so nervous that
someone was gonna find my blog.
So I got fired.
I changed it for accuracy
purposes to Girl With No Job,
took to Instagram a long time ago
where the only person--
I was a freshman in college,
so like five or six years ago.
Where the only person I knew
on Instagram was Perez Hilton.
He was like the first person on.
- That's an OG right there.
- Rest in peace.
Yeah, rest in peace.
- No, he's alive.
- No, I meant his brand.
- I DMed him yesterday.
(Claudia laughs)
Here's the good news,
Perez can flip it up.
Like this is what's
great about the recall.
It's all about executing properly.
If you look at who's winning,
it's really funny to--
Look what Will Smith's doing.
Will Smith is about to take
over 'cause he's vlogging.
He got tired of not being
as relevant anymore.
Making 25 million, 30
million a film is exciting,
but once you've got money,
you want relevance again.
And you know what it takes?
Humility, that's why he's a beast.
He's humble enough to do it.
- Super beast.
- Right?
I think Perez--
Like Vine, I'm making a prediction.
It was put in Ethos, Vine
2 is gonna be the platform
that Perez rises like a fucking phoenix.
- I really hope not.
I've had enough.
- [Gary] Respect.
- Like since high school, I'm done.
- Well of course, 'cause
you read his blog every day.
- [Claudia] Every day in high school.
- He dominated 2009 to 2012.
- He dominated.
And how you can have such success
and just end up where you are is
just so upsetting.
- Where is he?
- Well he just released
a video on YouTube saying
that he's an addict, and
he didn't say to what.
- [Gary] Really?
- He said not to drugs or alcohol,
but he just has an addictive personality.
And I was just waiting for him
to say what he's addicted to.
And he didn't say.
- If he gets a face tattoo,
I'm gonna lose my shit.
(group laughs)
Alright, let's keep it going.
- Yeah, got fired, Girl With No Job,
built a brand on social.
Really the point of getting on social was
to drive traffic to
this website that I had.
- [Gary] Understood.
- Whereas, I kind of just fell
into entertainment culture
on social and never even
really picked back up
with the blog.
I just fell into
building a brand.
- What was your first
pop-off moment?
What happened?
What did you post?
- I posted a--
it was like a picture.
It was a Snapchat actually of a girl.
You know girls put their
thighs up on the beach,
and they look like hot dogs?
- Yes, hot dog legs.
- It was like actual, like
what you think you see,
and then it was actually a girl's fingers
pretending to be her thighs.
And it was not a beach,
it was like her computer.
And she was at work.
Like Instagram versus reality.
- Yes, and that just went?
- [Claudia] Yeah.
- And away you went.
- Yes, away I went.
I got like 6,000 followers in one day.
- Did you know Ben at this point?
- Yes, I did now.
- [Gary] Dating?
- Dating.
- [Gary] And did you text
him, be like, "What the fuck?"
- Yeah, no, we were dying.
We were just on my phone
scrolling and refreshing.
- And what was he doing
with his life at this point?
This is just me prying.
- We were still in college, right?
Ben?
- [Ben] I think I was working.
- Okay, I don't remember.
- [Ben] Think I was a senior.
- Alright, that's too much of you, Ben.
Next!
(group laughs)
So tell us your story, my man.
- Alright, I'm from the Bronx originally.
Moved to Long Island in high school.
That's where I learned how to speak white.
(group laughs)
- How quickly did you pick it up?
- Very quickly, very quickly.
- [Gary] It's easy to pick up.
- Well, here's what white people love.
This is today.
The Wire, the air horn
(mimicks air horn noise)
and white people love the
R. Kelly Ignition Remix.
- By the way, I love.
- I know!
- I love that song!
- I'm the whitest--
- And if I do a white wedding.
- That is the most accurate thing.
That song, I once played
on repeat the entire drive
from Wine Library, the liquor store,
to Atlantic City and back.
- Do you love that song?
- Yeah, I like it.
- You like it.
You don't love it, right?
- That's a universal song.
It's universal.
- It is universal.
- No, but I'm taking the hood.
It's okay, it's a good R. Kelly song.
- No, it's well respected
in the white community.
- But white people love it.
- What's the hood's
favorite R. Kelly song?
- Oh, there's too many.
- It's too many.
- There's songs that you won't know.
- Give me one.
I'm putting you on the spot.
- There's one
called Real Talk.
- [Gary] Everybody loves Real Talk.
- You know Real Talk?
- Of course.
- I don't.
- R. Kelly?
- Of course.
- No, everybody doesn't know that.
- No I agree.
- Why?
- You must've grown up
around black people.
- Yeah, I went to Mount
Ida College, 97% black.
- Yeah, Real Talk is
like a deep, deep cut.
No hook.
At the end he yells out, "Melvin!
"Pull up the car!"
(group laughs)
So I learned to DJ.
- White.
- And I learned white.
And I learned to DJ.
- Did you get good at tennis?
- No, no, no, no, no.
- Okay, you never went deep.
- Not that white.
- You didn't go deep, Long Island.
- No sport, I don't do any sports.
- Got it.
- That's why.
- Period?
- None.
- You are not athletic?
- I know, you now hate me.
- No I don't.
Do you like sports?
- Makes me like you.
- No I don't like sports.
- Now I hate you.
Keep going.
Not being athletic, no problem.
Hating sports, problem.
- I was talking,
so my dad died when I was young.
And I was talking to this other comedian
who's dad also died when he was young.
I think that has a big part of it
like you probably like follow it up.
- You know what's funny?
My dad worked every minute,
influenced nothing of mine
'cause we were immigrants
that never saw him.
It just we're kids in my neighborhood.
We're throwing a Nerf football.
There's a million--
You coulda had a cousin that was--
You know how that works.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Nonetheless.
- But that's where the music came from.
I got super, heavy into music.
I started DJing with this guy, DJ Riz.
He introduced me to Funkmaster Flex.
I start interning at the
radio station in '97,
worked for years.
- In 1997, the hot '97?
- Yeah.
- That's freakin' amazing.
- I was three years old.
- Yeah it's perfect.
- [Gary] Yeah, it's super meta.
- Years and years and
years work for no money
and just kept climbing,
climbing, climbing.
Eventually got the Morning Show,
which lasted seven years.
- [Gary] Which was a huge run for you.
- Yeah, I was at the radio
station for 17 years.
In between, I'm doing DJ for Lil' Kim.
I A&R-ed at Star Trak,
which is Pharrell's label.
I A&R-ed at Rockefeller.
I've done a lot of things in between.
- It's funny you bring
up Lil' Kim this morning.
Literally this morning, I
sometimes think about my day
when I'm like brushing
my teeth, showering,
just thinking about it.
I was thinking about you talking
about the female rapper thing,
and I was like, man, there was a point
where I think Foxy Brown was
literally my favorite artist
in the world.
For like that little 48
seconds of that summer
when Pac and Biggie were dead,
and I was like fucked up and like fuck it.
Foxy's my number one.
Sorry, anyway.
Just rant when you said Kim
'cause that was the battle of the time.
Those two, it was kind of like fun.
So nonetheless.
- So yeah, in between there,
I DJ on the Chappelle Show.
I mean Dave Chappelle.
Then I'm funny on the radio,
so people start saying,
"You're funny, you're funny."
So I was like, alright.
People keep saying I'm funny.
Let me try to conquer
this comedy world.
- But on the radio,
and I've listened to your
stuff through the years,
was more like of an improv funny.
Like you were funny of the hip.
- All day.
- Not like,
I'm gonna do a set.
- [Cipha Sounds] Right, yeah.
- But people kept saying,
you're like, "Should I do a set?"
- Well, I just started
doing comedy to make money.
I'm gonna produce a comedy show.
I didn't think I was gonna do comedy.
- I get it.
- I was just like,
people keep thinking I'm funny.
Associate my name with funny.
- Oh you think I'm funny?
I'll show you how funny I am.
Give me your money.
- Yeah.
(group laughs)
So I did this night
called Don't Get Gassed.
It was one of the hottest comedy nights
for like five, six years.
And from that, I started doing stand-up.
At one point, I was just like, okay,
am I going to do this for real?
And I left the radio station.
At
39, 38 with a pregnant wife,
decide to start a whole new career.
- Good for you, man.
- And here I am.
- And how long has that been going on now?
- I've been doing stand-up
let's say eight years,
10, eight years.
But for real, where it's
my bread and butter,
like four or five years.
- Alright, let's go back around the table.
This is a segment that I
just made up five seconds ago
called, What Am I Obsessed With?
Like what is happening
right now in culture
or and/or your life that
you are obsessed with?
Saweetie.
- I am absolutely obsessed
with social media.
- Like the whole fuckin' thing?
- [Saweetie] Yes.
- Okay, let's rank them in
order of your obsession.
Number one, every other app has to die.
You can only live there.
It is...
- Instagram.
- Great.
- You sure?
- Okay, I was gonna say--
- Look, she has to think for a second.
- This is what happens.
I love Instagram, but I'm
starting to love Twitter
because I'm figuring out what works there.
It's all about figuring out what works
for different social media outlets.
- You found this new room.
It's like you found the den.
You've always been in the kitchen,
but you're like, "Wait!
"The den's kinda fuckin' cool.
"Like what can I do in here?"
So Twitter's emerging?
- Twitter, yeah, Twitter's emerging.
- [Gary] What else?
- That's about it.
- So those two?
So you're obsessed with Twitter
and Instagram and Twitter.
- Definitely, yeah.
- Period.
Okay, good.
No Job Girl.
- Yeah, I'm obsessed with everything.
I could talk about literally
anything till the end of time.
- But the number one thing
that you are obsessed with right now?
- Like stories and live streaming
like in real time content.
I use stories more than I actually post
on Instagram these days,
just because it feels super natural for me
'cause I started on Snapchat a while ago.
So just letting people know what I'm up to
at all hours of the day.
- Yes, and then seeing
how many people look at it
and what's going on.
- Right and obsessing over
the verified accounts
that watch my stories.
- Respect.
- Verified makes it better.
- [Claudia] Of course.
- That blue check is fuckin' status.
- Money.
- I see.
- The amount of money, hooking
up, and other random shit
that has been happening
because of that blue check
is fuckin' batshit crazy.
- Sheesh.
- People are starting to abuse it, though.
- Yeah.
- Meaning?
- Like getting themselves verified
when I just don't feel
like they deserved it.
- What if 90% shouldn't be verified?
- Excluding us.
- What are you absolutely
obsessed with?
- I'm obsessed with all the dope TV shows
that are out right now.
And I wanna make, make, make TV shows.
- [Gary] You wanna make TV shows?
- Yeah, that's what I wanna do.
- [Gary] So what's your number
one dopest, freshest TV show?
- I can't break it down.
I break it down in categories.
- You're gonna have
to break it down.
- No I'm saying like--
- No I got it.
I'll give you the airtime
to say every one of them,
but then you're gonna have
the final fuckin' four
and pick one.
- Right now, Handmaid's Tale--
- Yup.
Is sick.
- Fucked up.
- You know what I'm saying?
But then I also love stand-up
specials like Tom Segura.
Netflix is killing it.
- You know what's so funny?
It's just pattern recognition.
It's exactly what HBO
did in its early days.
Like comedy is always a pillar,
just like sports, just
like music, fashion.
Comedy is such a pillar of our society.
And what I love right now about Instagram
and you've gotta give a shout out to Vine
'cause comedy absolutely played out there.
And definitely, obviously
now Netflix and podcasts
for that matter.
I think for a lot of
people, comedy has reemerged
as an obvious pillar.
For example, if you guys
talk in your age group,
like seven, 10 years ago,
like five, six, seven, eight years ago,
it wasn't like comedy
was that in our face.
- [Claudia and Saweetie] No.
- You go back to Myspace with Dane Cook
and the tail end of Adam Sandler CDs
and the Jerky Boys, I'm old as shit.
- No the Jerky Boys are good.
- Bring that up.
But there's these moments
whether it's comedy or sports
or music, they pop up in
reminding us how important--
I think comedy's having a moment.
- Yeah, comedy used to
be a super slow burn.
You had to be on the road for 15 years.
- Like so traditional.
- To get recognized, yeah.
And now there's so many
different ways to see it
and so many different ways to do it.
It's definitely poppin' off.
- Do you feel native to
doing comedy on Instagram?
Does that come natural to you?
- No.
No, I love--
- Do you want it to?
- I struggle with that because
I really love live stand-up
in a club, and I feel
that's getting overshadowed
by people doing it on social media.
- So it's funny.
For me, when I hear that, I feel like that
everything is tried and true.
Like to me, I think it's addition to.
- [Cipha Sounds] Yes.
- I think we're having
way too many conversations
of and/or instead of and, right?
- Yeah, I agree.
- I think one of my favorite
things about young people
is that everything's in play now.
So I love hip-hop.
It's crazy to me that there
was only one move in hip-hop
when I grew up in the early to mid 90s,
which was if you're not hard, you're out.
And now, I literally think
like Lil Yachty woulda got
his face beat in in four seconds.
Like you can't dress, you can't do that.
Now you can do everything.
- Anything.
As long as you've got skills,
which I think is important.
Alright, fine, good.
Girl With No Job, what is
your ambition going forward?
I think you're in a very unique
spot from my perspective.
You have a lot of leverage
'cause you have a big audience.
We've mentioned Tumblr.
We've mentioned Snapchat.
I'm giving you smart cred
off your husband being smart.
I'm sure he learned everything from you.
- It's definitely true.
- So you're clearly smart.
Where do you sit on the
paranoia of is Instagram gonna
be the most important thing
for the next 12 months, 24
months, 48 months, 72 months?
How else am I spreading this out?
What am I doing with this?
How are you thinking about
this unique moment where 99%
of the people listening are
trying to get to a place
where they could live on
the back of these platforms?
You are in that but I don't
anything even through Ben.
I don't know, but I know
what your account is,
which means to me that you
easily could live your life
with that as a media property.
But you're also smart enough to know
there's a vulnerability and so
many people have been burned
on being one dimensional just YouTube,
one dimensional just Twitter,
Myspace we mentioned earlier.
Like Tila Tequila should still be relevant
if she was able to be
relevant in every sea change.
People get emotional and
say, well this is the thing.
I don't like this new thing,
but that new thing's gonna
kill you unless you embrace it.
- Yeah and I literally wake up everyday,
and I'm afraid of the
fact that I don't know
what the cool new app is.
And anytime I meet a 12
year old who knows who I am,
I'm like, "What do you do on your phone
"when you're laying in bed?
"What apps do you like,
what don't you like?"
And for a while, I lived in
fear that Instagram was on
its way down and that
Snapchat was where it was at.
So I put so much time and resources
into building a successful Snapchat,
which now just bit me in the ass
'cause I had a successful
Snapchat and nobody cares anymore.
- So are you numbers showing
you that nobody cares anymore?
- Actually, my numbers
are still really strong.
Just from a like a--
- Cultural relevancy.
- Yeah, like a cool perspective,
I just don't think that
people are thinking
that Snapchat is cool anymore.
And as a user, I'm so loyal to Snapchat.
I think it put a face to my brand,
and my brand wouldn't be the same
if it weren't for Snapchat.
If I see something I wanna capture,
my hand literally just goes to Snapchat,
and that's starting to change
because I'm recording more
on Instagram Stories now
than I am on Snapchat
because there's a bigger audience.
For me, it's like a built-in audience.
It already exists, and
it's just they're doing
such a better job.
Like for me, I use it as a
broadcasting opportunity,
Snapchat does not help creators
whatsoever find new audiences.
Instagram is putting my
stories on the suggested page.
It's helping me find users who
would have no idea who I am.
Oh sorry. (chuckles)
Who would have no idea who I am.
(group laughs)
- Just for everybody, this is a podcast,
so you didn't see that.
But she looked at her
phone, something clearly
was on the phone, either
a notification or a note,
and just distracted.
- I'm not good with that.
- Building out--
- If I could snap my fingers
right now and say with all
the leverage you have now,
what would be the number one next move
that's outside of your norm
of being a content creator?
- Okay, there's two.
It requires a one A and then step two
because I need to just build
out my digital portfolio
a little bit more before I
wanna move to traditional media,
so I wanna have a bigger
and better YouTube,
a bigger and better everything.
So I'm more well-rounded
so that by the time I get
to where a dream scenario
is like a young edition
of The View, where we talk about things
that young people care about,
not that like Rosie O'Donnell cares about.
I need to have a full portfolio
of where people know me.
- Do you think Rosie is old?
- I love Rosie.
I think she's so smart.
I don't know why The
View is always my example
for what's wrong in modern media,
but I'm a 23 year old woman,
and I don't feel like I'm
represented by The View.
- No, it's not for you, though.
- But I don't think I'm
represented in daytime--
- [Cipha Sounds] What about the The Real?
- It's close, it's better.
But I don't feel like I'm
represented in modern media,
especially daytime media,
where there are people my age
or close to my age talking about things
that I give a shit about.
- The overt respect for linear television
in this room is disgusting.
Next, Saweetie.
What do we want?
Are you in the mindset
that you're just eventually,
you and the team are
gonna put out the song
that changes the narrative of your career?
Is that where your mind's at?
- What do you mean by that?
- Are you in the mindset
of I gotta keep working
on the work, putting out good projects,
and that inevitably, one of those--
Like to me, it's amazing to me
how interesting the music game is to me.
I struggle with
finding a way that people pop outside
of either the album or the single song.
It's a very straightforward game,
which is that is the moment
that changes so many things.
It's either that hook, that song,
or that cameo or that album.
Are you just thinking hardcore
let me be about my craft,
let me keep being better at my craft,
let me keep putting out great songs,
and I'll take it from there?
- I would say that's one of the factors.
However, what's constantly
on my mind is marketing
'cause that song or that
hook or that, whatever it is,
I need to make sure that
I'm always capitalizing
on my audiences to ensure
that when I do release that,
it touches a wide range of
people so that it can pop off.
Because without marketing,
without thinking
about that everyday, you're
missing the opportunity
of expanding your audience.
- And you're at the mercy of other people.
- Exactly.
If I'm always thinking
about widening my range
of whoever's viewing my work,
that's the number one thing on my brain.
Because if you're not doing
that, then you might--
- How much music can we expect from you
in the next 12 months?
Gut feel.
You may not have the answer
for that, but intuitively,
how much music can we expect from you?
What do you think?
- I would say maybe two or three projects.
- [Gary] And are projects like
six, seven, eight, nine songs?
- Albums?
- [Gary] Or three songs?
- I would say 10 to 12 songs.
- [Gary] Got it.
- Three projects in the next year.
- Two to three.
- Wow.
That nowadays, that's not even a lot.
You know what I'm saying?
That's a good amount.
Back in the day where you
put an album out every year
and a half, two years.
Now music is flying out.
- Well we have the microwave generation.
- No, I know, but that's why
you also pay so--
- Not only that,
you have no fuckin' friction.
Like you should.
My big thing is as many
songs as you have in you,
you need to get out because
you're not at the mercy
of somebody at the radio
station or MTV or the label.
This is phenomenal.
This is the most democratized
music has ever been.
There's some kid right now
listening like in Ottawa, Canada,
who's gonna put something on SoundCloud
that's 40 seconds away from poppin'.
- Yeah.
- No, like when Icy Girl
went viral, my song,
someone in Dubai sent
me the picture of them
on the beach with my song.
- [Cipha Sounds] Instant.
- And I'm just like, what the hell?
- Once you press that button
and the music, you press send,
the music goes across the world instantly.
- [Saweetie] Exactly.
- I remember back in the day
and I don't wanna sound old,
but I'm old like you.
I used to go to Japan.
I'd play a lot of 90s hip-hop
because they were so far behind,
and then as I'm watching
the technology grow,
they're up on the song--
- They're like, "Oh.
"There's new shit."
That came out today.
"Run DMC."
- Yeah it's crazy.
- No I get it.
- The whole world, music just changed.
- Everything is changed.
Information is moving at
a totally different light.
- But that's why you're saying
you're so into marketing
because you know the music
is only half of the battle.
- Exactly.
- So many people put out music
you have to be on top of that other half
where like back in the day,
artists were just artists.
There were some who were
more entrepreneurial,
but they just made good
music and then they had--
Hopefully it would go.
Now you're so on top of it.
- No because audiences
and fans aren't interested
in the artist who is a typical celebrity.
They're interested in the artist who is
like your everyday person
and who is accessible.
- And who could talk to them.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Who do you wanna most work with?
Gimme two or three names, just for fun.
- Like work with as
business or musically or--
- Whatever you want.
- I'd wanna say I'd wanna work
with Dr. Dre, only because
I saw his documentary
with Jimmy Iovine and their mad scientist.
I like Drake.
I like what he's done
with OVO and his branding.
He's constantly marketing.
- You know what, real quick, I apologize.
I think what Drake is really smart with
and I thought it was what I
think one of the best moves
of the year was the
humility he decided to show
in the commercial with his dad, right?
You have to understand,
this is all high school.
This will always be high school.
The second you figure out
somewhere for most people
between sophomore and
junior year of high school
where you're like, "Oh shit, right.
"If I make fun of myself
and I laugh at myself
"with my friends, they'll
stop picking on me."
Understanding the moves, I
think Drake's understanding
of anthropology and psychology of like
if I put a national
commercial for my beverage on,
where I get clowned and my dad
gets the girl, that is smart.
There's not a lot of people
who have the humility
and the confidence.
- Especially in hip-hop.
- Correct.
- 'Cause you were saying
like everyone wants to be--
- Correct.
They wanna be hard.
- That's why Drake wins
'cause he showed (mumbles).
- 100%.
- And he's hot, so.
- [Cipha Sounds] And he's hot.
- Helps.
- Hello.
(Saweetie laughs)
- When Drake's with his hardcore beard,
do you think he's hotter?
What Drake is hot?
- Drake is the American dream.
Like he was on Degrassi.
And that was like the number one--
- [Gary] That's the Canadian dream.
(group laughs)
There's not a fuckin' American
that knows what Degrassi is.
- Everyone knows what Degrassi is!
- Because of him.
- No, no!
- Why do you know what Degrassi is?
- Everyone watched it!
- No Degrassi was on
in the states.
- It was like the dark show
where you learned what bad things were.
- What were you watching it on?
Like Nick at Nite or some shit?
- Yeah, literally.
- Alright, keep going.
- What were you saying?
- [Gary] He's the dream.
- He's the American dream.
He just went from that.
Do you know any of the
other kids on Degrassi?
No, and now Drake is Drake.
- I met some of the other kids.
- One name wonder.
- No, I always remember
the girl with the thong.
- Yeah, do you know her name?
- No. (laughs)
- My point.
- [Gary] What's the big North Star for you
in the short term?
What's the next thing
you'd want to happen?
- So what I did, I kind of left music,
started doing this comedy thing,
but what I realized and
what I discovered is that
combining them, I'm creating my own lane.
So I combined my hip-hop friends
and all my history with comedy.
So I do an improv show at UCB
where I get hip-hop artists
to come tell real-life stories
and then me and a bunch
of improvisors make up a
whole show on the spot.
- I love that.
- You know what I'm saying?
And then what I do at
Dave Chappelle, I DJ,
like when we did Radio City,
we was there almost a whole month.
- [Gary] I remember.
- I DJ, but I'm cracking
jokes while I'm DJing.
'Cause no one else can DJ and do stand-up.
If they're out there, I'm
gonna slice your neck.
I'm not the greatest comedian.
I'm a very good DJ.
Combining it, no one's in my lane.
- [Gary] I love it
- I make my own path.
- I love it.
What can I do for you?
Let's go back around the other way.
You first.
- I would say help me get to
as many followers as she has,
but you already do that
'cause I watch all your videos
and learning everyday.
- How'd you come across it?
Do you remember?
- Your stuff?
- Mm-hmm.
- Just on Instagram, just
people posting all your stuff.
And what kills me about you, what I love
when someone catches you in
a hallway or after you speak
or something, and they
ask you the question,
and you give them the
straightforward answer.
And they blank look, and
they want this trick.
And you're like, no.
Get in the trenches and work your ass off.
Four years, no, ten years.
You know what I'm saying?
And just keep going, and they're like,
"Yeah, but how do you--"
No, no, no, I answered you already.
- I really do need a yeah but T-shirt.
'Cause that's usually the answer
to almost everything I say.
Yeah but.
- Yeah, and it's like dude,
he told you the answer.
I love that straightforwardness.
- I appreciate it.
Girl With No Job, what can I do for you?
- Do you know Andy Cohen?
- [Gary] Yes, I know Andy Cohen.
- I would love to also know Andy Cohen.
Just like a personal favor.
- Love it.
- And I would also just love to--
- [Gary] Tyler, text Eric Wattenberg.
Let's set it up.
- Stop.
Yes, coffee or drinks.
- Which would you prefer?
- Drinks, obviously.
I flourish with a drink.
- [Gary] What would you order?
- Oh, it depends where we go.
I would want to come off as like a lady
but also like a cool--
So probably like a vodka soda.
- Got it.
What do you think Andy would order?
- Oh, for sure like an old
fashion or like a whiskey.
Oh, he drinks whiskey, yeah.
- Yes.
And who's Andy's favorite music artist?
- John Mayer.
- [Gary] Very good, keep going.
Now we will actually introduce you.
- I would love to sit
with you for 30 minutes
and just discuss the social landscape.
I'm fairly certain I know what's going on
in the digital space but maybe I'm wrong.
- You wanna just triple check?
- Yeah, I just wanna double
check that I'm doing everything
right.
- Just wanted a triple check.
- Yeah like triple check.
- 'Cause Ben's gonna be there.
(group laughs)
Saweetie, what can I help you with?
- Two things.
- Go ahead.
- So I've seen the interview
you did with A-Boogie.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And I saw you mention Cap'n Crunch.
- I wanna do something with them.
- [Gary] You love Cap'n Crunch?
- I love Cap'n Crunch.
- Me too.
- Every black kid love Cap'n Crunch.
- [Cameraman] Almost killed you.
(group laughs)
- Wait, is this true?
Every black girl loves Cap'n Crunch?
- Every black kid.
- [Gary] Kid, everybody loves
Cap'n Crunch period.
- Yeah, no, us too.
(group laughs)
- The Long Island whites
love Cap'n Crunch.
Okay, understood.
Mike Boyd, let's put that on the docket.
You have a second thing.
- Second thing, I wanna learn
how you built your team.
I love the interview
you did with A-Boogie.
I feel like you shed so many gems.
I feel like building the correct team
around you is really important.
We're expanding
as the day goes.
- While I'm wrapping up and I apologize.
Everybody's gonna feel
it that I'm wrapping up
'cause I got the entire
company in four minutes
that I have to address, and so
I'm gonna bounce out of here.
This is a good thing to end with
because I think everybody
listening will get value
out of this, so I appreciate
the last thing you said.
There's several things that
matter in building a team.
Number one, the biggest
mistake people make is
they think people work for them
instead of them working
for that team member.
I think the biggest
reason I've had success is
I genuinely think I work for Tyler
and Jake and Tyler and DRock.
It's my responsibility as the
North Star to the last line
of defense to create the
framework for them to flourish,
not for them to be at my beck
and call, and I'm the leader.
It's a really interesting mindset,
but I think you start
building actual teams
when everything that's fucked
up is your fault as the A,
the number one, and that everything
that's working is shared with them.
So for everything that's broken
with us, I take on with me.
It's not Andy or DRock or
Tyler's fault, it's my fault.
And everything that's working
is a lot me, I believe that,
but I also think a lot of them
picking up on those nuances.
That's number one.
Number two, all three of
you have the following
amazing opportunity, and
I mentioned it early.
And it's really ironic with
the Girl With No Job story.
I believe we're living
in an incredible time.
I believe that if you're a young--
Let me use you as the example.
If you were a 14 year old,
if you were an 18 year old young woman
that has enormous aspirations
to be in the music business.
That interning for you and
the team for six months
and not getting paid.
And we talked about it earlier.
But if it's for somebody
who's got something going on,
and obviously, anybody
who's bigger than you
and whether that's more albums
sold, more songs downloaded,
more experience, what have you.
But back to the Dubai thing,
all three of you have, on a terrible day,
100 psychotic fans and
not psychotic, weird, bad.
I mean all-in, fuck with you heavy.
They're all about you.
Of those 100 people, I'm
gonna say it for me too.
It's not a big number.
I mean people that are like
in Portland, Oregon right now,
that if you DM them and said,
"I want you to follow me around."
They would be in the room
right now and photography me
and video me and post-edit
me and make more copies.
They would rip their
arm off, get on a plane,
and fly and be part of your team.
The fact that in the same
way anybody can pop now,
anybody can make music,
that you can build a team
before you have the
finances to afford the team
'cause it's an even trade.
It's an even trade.
Girl With No Job, do you know how many--
- Does the government see it that way?
- Well listen, you have to abide by laws,
and if there's a state law--
Like I would want that, but
I think there's a minute
because it's under the Vayner world.
As a human, I don't know.
Consult your lawyer.
The reality is, here's my thing.
The amount of women that
aspire to be you right now.
I know a lot of them, right?
I don't know what else to tell you.
I genuinely believe
that Lisa Schwartzman--
- She's totally Jewish, 100%.
- In Millburn fuckin' New Jersey right now
will get way more
fuckin' value for working
for free for you for six months.
- She's welcome.
- Than 99.9% of the
shit she could be doing.
- I totally agree, and
if she wants to email me,
that's fine.
- That has to play out.
- Yeah.
- You have to understand, guys.
In 1947, going to college
wasn't the right thing to do.
It was getting a vocational skill.
Shit changes.
You wanna hear something crazy?
Not only do I think in 20 years,
the version of you is not gonna pay,
I think the person's gonna pay you
for the right to even be in your circle.
- Well she should.
- I think so.
But I'm telling you right now.
Do you know how many fuckin' people,
who want to be exactly
what you can teach them,
are gonna pay four thousand
dollars for some bullshit
fuckin' course right now?
- Totally.
- So building a team.
First, you work for them.
Period, end of story,
from now till the end,
till you put that
fuckin' star in Hollywood
on the ground in the cement.
You work for them.
It's a big mind shift, and
most people don't get it.
And that's why most
people don't fuckin' win.
Number two, take advantage of the moment.
There's a lot of fuckin'
kids trying to build up
their comedy.
- Oh, I've built interns
who are now stars who came from my camp.
- [Gary] I get it.
- They're out there.
They'll do it.
- I think that's
the other thing, and literally,
it's like an Instagram Story
or Instagram post or tweet
of like looking for five hustlers.
Like I don't have much to pay right now,
but I'll show you the world.
I'll show you the inside.
It's real, it's very, very, very real.
And for everybody listening,
some of you don't have the money,
and you think you can't compensate.
And you think you're
doing the wrong thing.
If your intent is right--
So the reason I'm never
scared of paying minimum wage
or having a resident
or an intern is I know
that I'm always capable
of settling the score.
If they're so fuckin' remarkable,
if they do so much greater
than what they got paid,
I can always do something down the line,
and if you know you're up to something,
and you've got something going on,
you could always settle the
score in the fourth quarter.
So if you have the right intent,
I'm not trying to steal from them.
I'm trying to get my value.
Good relationships are
when both people get value.
- [Saweetie And Cipha Sounds] Right.
- The end.
Alright, one last thing
you can leave them with
and I gotta go.
One last thing for everybody listening.
What should they know, what do you want?
Do you want them to follow?
- You said it all.
- [Gary] What you want?
- Me personally, I don't
know how anyone else did it.
I know how I did it.
I get in the room, I work
for free, I show my value,
then people don't want me to leave.
- [Gary] Leverage.
- That's always how I do it.
- [Gary] Where can people find you?
- @ciphasounds, C-I-P-H-A
and the word sounds.
Please.
Oh at truTV, I got a
new show on truTV, yeah.
I forgot, I'm sorry.
I got a new comedy show on truTV.
- Girl With No Job,
Instagram, Facebook, Twitter,
all that stuff.
Claud With No Job, you know
building my personal brand.
- [Gary] Respect.
- Doing a live show for my podcast,
doing a live show at Carolines,
just look me up.
I'm everywhere.
- Saweetie, S-A-W-E-E-T-I-E.
Instagram and Twitter and car raps
to doing my first show in
Turkey, Istanbul, next week.
- Wow.
- Nice.
- Whatever you can do out there, kids.
Social media, take advantage of it.
- Wow.
- Love it.
Guys, thanks for being on the show.
- Thank you, Gary.
- Thank you.
- Podcast.
Please leave some social comments for me.
Feedback to what you
think about the format.
I'm excited as fuck as this.
I got lucky.
All three of them did their thing.
This was good, this flowed.
We might have to take this on tour.
- On the road.
- Anderson and Andy
have their little thing.
- I know, AC2.
- The four of us in Carnegie.
- Oh no, murder.
- Murder.
- Murder that.
- It'd be poppin'.
- See ya!